- Yeah, you know,
I've been in and out of
jail since I was nine.
Like for real, you know what I'm saying?
And it just come and translate
to certain things like
how I fold my clothes,
how I tuck my shirt in,
the way I eat my food.
You know.
Just shit liked that.
You know what I'm saying?
With these folk that been out here
It just like, they don't do it the same.
It's like certain people could tell
I been locked up sometime.
I be trying to distance
myself from that shit
they calling it being institutionalized.
You know what I'm saying?
I swear I ain't.
But then people around me some of my hoes
especially my mama
she swore up and down and
nigga institutionalized me.
- [Interviewer] How far
did you go in school?
- I got my GED.
I dropped out in ninth grade though.
Yeah, after the ninth grade,
this shit was over with.
You know what I'm saying?
My big brother was deep in the streets.
I'm talking about, he
the reason I'm a gangster
you know what I'm saying?
But he didn't have a
pimp bone in his body.
He really was a sucker for a hoe.
You know what I'm saying?
He hard on a nigga
but when it comes to a bitch
take them down through though.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] How'd you grow up?
You had both parents?
- My dad was the primary role.
What do you want to say?
Primary or caregiver or however
you want to say that shit.
My mama was on it hard.
Yeah, she smoked the crack
you know what I'm saying?
She was a hustler though.
A bonafide hoe too you
know what I'm saying?
A real hustler though
you know what I'm saying?
Nigga, my first vivid memory of my mama
she taught me how to roll a little socks
and stuff them in my pants,
you know what I'm saying?
It was me, my little brother, Jazz
rest in peace , GIP my little brother Dig.
But me, him, my uncle
Charles, and my mama.
You know what I'm saying?
We used to go through the store.
Man burn this thing up
TJ Max give us all this shit
until they mouth out.
She used to say, y'all
better not let a motherfucker
touch y'all mama.
You know what I'm saying?
So before I even started hustling,
before I even start pimping,
you know what I'm saying?
Anything, I was secured.
You know what I'm saying?
My mama neighborhood, he rode everybody
in Mitchell Headden,
he don't know my mama.
You know what I'm saying?
You say Ms Sharon, her
name ring a 1000 bills.
You know what I'm saying?
So I was always around
different little scenes.
You know what I'm saying?
Cleaning paper with the Texas
in, you know what I'm saying?
The car fraud shit, you
know what I'm saying?
Real bonafide hoe 'cause my
mama was a certified hoe.
I'm talking about, her name
ring from here to Albuquerque.
You know what I'm saying?
Like for real, you know what I'm saying?
And my daddy was a square
you know what I'm saying?
Country boy from Griffin Georgia.
Mama put that puss on, fast talking him
and she blew his , they
ended up having five kids.
You know what I'm saying.
And my mama got nine all
together, five by my dad
and my daddy had got shot
and killed over our hoe.
You know what I'm saying?
Over a hoe and I was like
seven.
Seven, eight year old.
That's when my life just
took a drastic change.
You know what I'm saying?
I probably wouldn't even not be here.
In this state right here
I probably be a college
educated ass square quiet boy
or something fucking with my pop
'cause then how serious he
took our upbringing was.
You know what I'm saying?
Versus coming back here with
Sharon and here with my mama.
It was night and day.
You know what I'm saying?
Like she embraced the streets,
you know what I'm saying?
It wasn't no keeping around.
It was get up out of her type.
Shit go outside and play.
Don't go in your room, take
your ass outside and play.
So with that you know
Memphis a motherfucker.
You know what I'm saying?
It's eat or get ate out here.
One thing I had a natural
inclination towards.
I caught on quick, you feel?
I was out serious, I
ask a lot of questions.
What's that for?
Why you cocked the gun out like that?
Why you load the bullets like that?
Why are you cut it like that?
When you put heat on it what?
Why you put baking soda with...
I always asked a 1000 questions.
You know what I'm saying?
To the point where I
had to shut up sometimes
you know what I'm saying?
Cause you can't be in the
car asking questions .
You know what I'm saying?
You're around gangster,
killer, pimp, raw murderers.
- [Interviewer] Did you carry a gun?
- Yeah always.
- [Interviewer] Where's your gun?
- It's close
- [Interviewer] You got
started in the game when?
- Which part of the game
like you telling me are strictly pimping?
Strictly pimping .
My baby mama, that's
the first mother fucker
that introduced me to the game.
I'm talking about like, my hoe, my doe.
You know what I'm saying?
My spot.
I had shot a nigga ass, paralyzed him.
I was fighting a little charge and shit
I was on the $90,000 bond.
Really, like I ain't got a pot piss in
a window to throw it out of.
You know what I'm saying?
And one thing about my hoe Crystal
She always wanted to be there for daddy.
She brought it to me straight like this :
if I could show you
that I can make more money in one night
than you selling dope.
Will you put the set down?
She peeked my interest.
I'm like bitch then show me,
you know what I'm saying?
In my I'm like, I'm finna
cut this little cash
from this hoe and still work the set.
But my that my money was so sweet.
It was so fucking sweet.
When I saw that she
just talked to this man.
I'm talking about talk.
She ain't even fuck this man.
Just off this conversation you heard me?
This man coming down with this bread.
It's that easy,
You know what I'm saying?
It's dead simple.
Okay, then we finna make
a lifestyle out the shit.
You know what I'm saying?
And from that day forward
I dibble and dabble with the
set, you know what I'm saying?
For hustling, selling
rocks, weed, all that shit.
I dibble and dabble but my main...
I could pay shit with pimping and panning.
You know what I'm saying?
I can't repeat everything about me.
- [Interviewer] So
you've done prison time?
- Yeah.
[Interviewer] You just got out.
- Yeah recently, July.
[Interviewer] How y years?
- Ten year, three months.
- [Interviewer] What for?
My attempted murder,
possession with a intention
manufactured little seal.
Introduction to a penal facility
'cause when I was locked up,
I was still trying to get it in.
You know what I'm saying?
I ain't got an extra two
point seven for that.
Two years, seven months for that shit.
And I just got out from that shit
You know what I'm saying?
I got locked up in 2010.
I first had caught the charges in 2007.
So I fought it for three years
you know what I'm saying?
Running back and forth,
in and out the state
you know what I'm saying?
That she shit finally
had caught up with me
I was on $150,000 bond,
pimping and pandering.
You know what I'm saying?
My hoe Crystal, the same one.
I ain't with the bitch now
but she fill a hoe spot
in my heart though.
You know what I'm saying?
A special spot in my pocket
you know what I'm saying?
Cause that hoe was the truth
in the booth you heard me?
And shit, they had had
Jamel 2010 and shit.
And she, I ain't see her another day
till shit July recently
you know what I'm saying
And she, even in her is
still with the same thing.
I'm a street nigga first and foremost.
I wasn't finna get in jail
and just turn into no, we
call them penitentiary niggas.
You know what I'm saying?
It's term that we use when we refer
to motherfuckers that's institutionalized.
The term that I spoke on earlier,
you know what I'm saying?
And I wasn't feeling a beat in .
You ought to see them niggas in there
you know what I'm saying?
Tripping over a soap, a
stamp of bowl of soup.
You know what I'm saying?
Life don't amount to shit,
they cared about the smallest things.
But being in that
pressure cooker situation
make you care about this shit,
you know what I'm saying?
Motherfucker
steal a pair of socks.
You know what I'm saying?
Misplace your commissary
form you don't get no food.
Shit like it.
Smile, shit like that, you
can get stabbed for it.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] So today
you have how y girls?
- I got four currently
you know what I'm saying.
Jasmine, Jessica,
I call them my little white bitch Pamela,
she got some age on them
you know what I'm saying?
I got my bottom bitch up
You know?
Hun she had a deal but
she take care of business
as long as she can you
know what I'm saying?
But you know, it's good always
to have another bottom
bitch in the making.
Yo feel me?
Can't let no hoe get too comfortable .
You know what I'm saying?
Feel like she gets you all the way
to the point where she got
you, you know what I'm saying?
When hopefully she know
everything about her pimp
she want a new one.
You know what I'm saying?
Hold on to her something
new, go someplace new,
be showing her something
new, worth something new,
feel new I don't want no old bad.
- [Interviewer] How easy
is it honestly for a girl
to get out if she wants to?
- To get out the game?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, in
order to leave a pimp.
- You know me.
It's all about the pimp you feel me,
It's all about the pimp .
How far you want to go
you know what I'm saying?
With me you know, I deal
with choice not force.
Now I used to deal with force not choice.
You know what I'm saying?
Hence the gorilla freed on my neck.
I used to be hard on a hoe.
You know what I'm saying?
My way or the highway.
Now I'm
a little bit lenient.
Did 10 years is a duty though.
You feel what I'm saying?
Ten years did make my a
little bit more understanding
- [Interviewer] But
the gorilla pimp style,
with the girl who may want
to get out means what?
- I mean, I ain't no
getting out with gorilla.
Bitch it's what I say it is,
you know what I'm saying?
For how long I say it is.
You know what I'm saying?
And you can go on and
pray about it to your God
bitch you could tell the
devil, it ain't gone change.
You know what I'm saying?
And then you know me.
It just would come and with
too much physical shit.
Every time I look up,
I got to slap this hoe
or jack this bitch up.
Look , it got to be a
better way, you feel?
So I wanted to master my craft
'cause before I went to jail
I would just, you know what I'm saying?
My big toes was in the game.
You know what I'm saying?
When I got out, it was
full-fledged pimping
you know pimping will die with
me you know what I'm saying?
I ain't going no other way, I
ain't trying no other route.
I'ma live and die this way
you know what I'm saying?
And once I fully made that commitment
It humbled me a little bit
because I felt like I knew more.
You know what I'm saying?
I could accomplish more.
I ain't have to go that route.
You see what I'm saying?
See, gorilla pimping really frustration.
- [Interviewer] It's what?
- Frustration.
He ain't got enough game to tame the hoe.
You see what I'm saying?
A pimp game game be longer
than this hoe money.
Fuck your money hoe, I'm rich forever.
You see what I'm saying?
But see, then I tickle
their mouths far enough
You know what I'm saying?
To present it that way, you
ain't going to get them results.
The results you want.
You see what I'm saying?
And see when a pimp don't
get the results he want,
that tend to frustrate a pimp.
Frustrated pimp whoop hoes.
I was that frustrated pimp.
You know what I'm saying?
Check my route script,
cleaner than I devise.
You know what I'm saying?
I will put the charge on a nigga
and won't even call it a preliminary ride.
Get thar thrown out.
I got about sick and mad
of them motherfuckers.
You know what I'm saying?
Check this shit , google me
this shit black and white on me.
You know what I'm saying?
If follow for like 17,
all the way up to like
19, 20
you know what I'm saying?
About 17, 19, 20 you know what I'm saying?
Right before I went to
the penitentiary though,
you know what I'm saying?
She started simmering down a little bit
how I started dealing with these hoes,
because I saw that I wasn't
getting the results I wanted.
So I'm like, shit I can't keep
going through this shit,
living like this shit.
I remember vividly .
It was 2009 Mardi Gras.
I was in new Orleans, me
and my first hoe Crystal.
She my baby mama too you
know what I'm saying?
It was me, her and her friend
you know what I'm saying?
That was a new bitch.
- [Interviewer] Can you sit?
- Yeah I'ma sit down I just be...
I like moving sometimes.
- [Interviewer] We can take
a break if you want to.
- No, we cool, we cool G.
But we in New Orleans,
my hoe new to the game, you feel me?
She probably had been hoe for
probably like eight months
after she did time, but she so googly-eyed
I once my hoe get a taste of their money.
They just want weed .
They get addicted more to weed.
You see what I'm saying?
See it don't always be
pimping that be the problem
Hoe be wanting to hoe.
Some hoe want to hoe.
They get a taste in his life
and get absorbed in it no
time out, consumed with it.
It become they life you feel me?
In a way, you know what I'm saying?
My hoe's still new to these streets
you know what I'm saying?
Tarika she what you call a V hoe,
a hoe that been in the game.
Been working in the streets
been in and out of state
you know what I'm saying?
She ain't no rookie at all
So this bitch already dealing
with this old busta-ass
simple-ass nigga ain't gotta...
I'm talking about busta-ass
nigga, shoes beat up
ain't got no car ain't got no
game you know what I'm saying?
The bitch just like him
you know what I'm saying?
Sometime the hoe choose up.
No, a lot of times the hoe choose up.
But I'll say this, sometime a
hoe make the pimp you feel me?
Any pimp will tell you
the bitch pimp got his
game from a hoe, you feel?
And in this situation .
Cause I ended up dealing with a nigga
that she giving the game to and
I ain't getting no game from
you know what I'm saying?
It just, ain't no good situation.
And then here I come
in fresh out the jail,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm on bond, $150,000 bond.
Nigga been hearing about me
cause I shot one of his homeboy.
You know what I'm saying?
He sleek don't want to
be in a car with me.
Still putting salt in
a hoe ear, you feel me?
Yeah, so we out of town
in New Orleans and shit.
The bitch get to arguing with the nigga
you know what I'm saying?
So I'm like, look, check this out, ,
look choose up and lose
one, fuck that sucker.
You know what I'm saying?
He don't got to ride back with us.
He can roll away with it
you know what I'm saying?
Leaving with them busta
ass shoes you found him in.
You feel me?
You know what I'm saying?
So my hoe CD, that was the first taste
my hoe CD getting at another
hoe hoe for the longest.
I just let the hoe go
and knock other hoes,
I played the post you
know what I'm saying?
Now I get gorilla with the hoe
when it be just me and them
you know what I'm saying?
I be getting my point across
and I'm going to make them understand me.
But for the most part G I played the post.
You know what I'm saying?
I worked my hoe day,
my hoe work these hoes
you know what I'm saying?
I ain't.
One thing about New
Orleans, their pimp killers
You know what I'm saying?
Them niggas gangsters
and murderers down there
dope sellers and shit down there.
They ain't with that pimping shit.
You know what I'm saying?
Them folks hit a booty club,
they just want to throw
their cash, see some ass.
You know what I'm saying?
They see, you know what I'm saying?
The hoe first told me, you
can't be my boyfriend here.
You can't say we're together
I'm like bitch what you mean?
Hoe you mines, bitch what you mean?
She like, nah, they pimp
killers down her for real daddy,
you gotta be this way.
Always listen to your hoe G you heard me?
You knock her properly, listen to her
'cause she gonna guide you feel me?
You're going to guide her,
she going to guide you.
This how this shit work,
you know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] So is
there a romantic connection
with your girls or just one of them?
- Two of them.
The other two I ain't never fuck.
I ain't never let them eat the dick
I ain't never got a dick pic from a pimp.
Strictly game, strictly it is what it is.
You know what I'm saying?
But the other two, you
know what I'm saying?
I fuck them here and there
you know what I'm saying?
I try to, you know what I'm saying?
You gotta master your
little dick you heard me?
You got to , you know what I'm saying?
'Cause if you don't,
a hoe going to put you in
the same category as a trick.
You know what I'm saying?
This dealt to a pimp you heard me?
Yeah hoe we ain't the same at all.
And don't never misconstrue this shit
don't ever play with me
like it is you heard me?
But see that's on you though.
If you come to fucking and what
we call, risk saving a hoe.
Man or one, you going to be on broke pimp.
You heard me?
And two, you're going to
be simple ass chilly pimp.
Hoes going to treat you like anything.
Hoe going to pay you
when she want pay you.
And that ain't what's
going on you hear me?
That's not what's going on
period you know what I'm saying?
But you gotta put your
foot down from the door.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause you don't, like I said,
the hoe going to run all over you.
But like mine flag back,
holding me in the water.
Like I said the hoe got
to arguing with the nigga
You know what I'm saying?
I had to read the nigga his rights.
I was the top nigga,
nigga you in my car nigga.
Matter of fact, both
of these hoe mine nigga
you can creep where you came in.
You know what I'm saying?
And see that was the first
time my hoe had seen me
ever take up for another hoe
speak good on another hoe.
End of it and it made the hoe jealous.
- [Interviewer] What
what's what's the advantage
of working with a pimp for the girl?
- The advantage of working
with a pimp for girl.
- [Interviewer] Why don't
they just go renegade?
- A hoe might get killed,
you know what I'm saying?
It's just the benefits that
come with working with it.
I'm secured, I'm protection
you know what I'm saying?
My name black and gold in street.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm talking about from north
Memphis to the south Memphis
to Warewood long mile
man, Frijoles Cinco known
you know what I'm saying?
So this a level, see a hoe
don't want to be a part
of some powerful, she don't
want no rinky dink ass,
scape rink ass pimp, you heard me?
No common store ass pimp,
no local Joe ass pimp.
No , you know what I'm saying?
It's a difference between 513 and CNN,
you see what I'm saying?
How want to go around the globe.
You see what I'm saying?
Hoe know she can't do that
with no average Joe blow-ass nigga.
You feel me?
You know what I'm saying?
That's why you got to come,
pimping paint a big picture.
You heard me?
You know what I'm saying?
We see dreams we don't buy
them you know what I'm saying?
And, and we did mine.
You got to always make a hoe feel special,
make a hoe know she a part
of something powerful.
You know what I'm saying?
I done seen hoes purposely
put they self in situations
to see if their pimp could save them.
To see if their nigga
going to come through
like he say he going to do
and save them you feel me?
A hoe will try you like that
you know what I'm saying?
See if he bought what he talking about
Let me check this nigga
pocket, check this nigga boot.
You know what I'm saying?
You know I always came correct,
I was thugging.
Since early I've been out the porch.
I've been out of the porch.
Like I been getting to a bag,
I been getting me some money
before for the hoe money,
you know what I'm saying?
My whole primary objective with me
was to get me to put the
sac down you feel me?
She wanted me to stop selling hard,
stop selling sulfur you
know what I'm saying?
And shit man strictly
the hoe really wanted me
all to herself too you feel me?
That's another thing too
you will find these old
want-me-want-her-way pimps.
You know what I'm saying?
Wasting their time, trying
to calm and reassuring
and calmly appease these
bitch and baby boo,
this sucker ass shit.
And get what?
They're going to be the broke pimp
you ever seen in your
motherfucking life you heard me.
Nah, I ain't doing none of that.
You know what I'm saying?
I ain't doing none of that
and I peeped that from her.
Cause I went through the experience early.
When I was 17, 18.
Seeing how a hoe trying
to cuff me all to herself.
You know what I'm saying?
Didn't want to spread that pimping around.
You know, it was all
good when I would let her
go and knock all the hoes
and talk for me and all that
but then when pimping
stepped in the lime light,
when they shot this shit for
real, all the hoe clamp up.
You know what I'm saying?
She wants to read a fool,
you know what I'm saying?
Because I came on the sucker,
shit cause it was love first.
You know what I'm saying?
So I see.
It made something clear to me you feel me?
You can't turn a hoe out
and have longevity with this hoe.
It just don't work like that you feel me?
Cause the hoe on going to feel betrayed
You can't go from daddy to
broke you see what I'm saying?
Say
you turn a hoe out versus knocking a hoe
that's already a full fledged hoe.
You see what I'm saying?
See what the full fledged hoe
it's pimping from the door
You see what I'm saying?
She know what it is out the top.
You know what I'm saying?
And anything this is going
to be on our demonstration.
How you come, you feel me.
All right, versus with this turnout,
you knocked this hoe from a lobby area,
from Walmart's or something.
When you got the hoe
number, woo and boo the hoe
you know what I'm saying?
And then you flip the script.
I'll beat, you plead with me.
You see what I'm saying?
You see the betrayal in the hoe heart.
- [Interviewer] So the
game has changed a lot.
- All right, from when I went in till now
oh it's a drastic change.
You know, with this technology,
shit space aged and everything
you know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] And penalties
are worse too right?
- You know I mean yeah they're wide.
Why I said , I prefer to shadow with mine.
You know what I'm saying?
This anomaly right here,
this ain't something I normally do.
Real talk like this ain't
something I normally do.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, no cap, like on my soul
I would have walked right past this way.
You know what I'm saying?
Had not not my hoe came and
told her what was going on.
You know what I'm saying?
Really vouched for you
you know what I'm saying?
look your ass would've
got robbed or something.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] That's what I'm doing
- You know what I'm saying so.
- [Interviewer] I've been robbed before.
- I believe, you know what I'm saying?
I believe bro, you know what I'm saying?
But you know, these pimps slay and murder.
I told you the slayer don't come out
till that ass come out.
- [Interviewer] So what kind of qualities
do you look for in a girl?
- I try to stay drool-free
but see you know got sac pimps too .
You got sac chasing at hoes too.
You know what I'm saying?
They see a pussy just
to supply their drool.
You know what I'm saying?
And mind you, you can pimp that way
but that shit ain't no longevity.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm trying to mind ladies.
You know it ain't about
what you get out here
it's about who lasts
the longest you feel me?
I did just done 10 years, three months.
You know what I'm saying?
I ain't trying to put myself
in no compromising situation.
None of that period you
know what I'm saying?
'Cause you know how this shit going to go
you know what I'm saying?
You might have to kill a
motherfucker, you might get killed.
You know what I'm saying?
You got to think like that.
You got to prepare yourself
for the worst situations
out here in the streets.
You know what I'm saying?
And especially dealing
with women you feel me.
They're emotional.
The emotion runs so high.
You know what I'm saying?
And tricks be...
Have you ever a tunnel-eyed vision trick
that don't want nothing but one thing.
You hear me?
I'm talking about, crazed
out of their pussy hole.
Like they're possessed you hear me.
I'm talking about I had
this one bitch named Bailey.
White bitch from Kentucky young bitch,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm 33 she was probably...
I'm 33 now this is when I was 20.
She probably was 33 then.
Via hoe, been in the game,
you know what I'm saying?
We used to call her Shirley Temple
she was had that blonde
hair with them ring curves,
thick little white bitch you heard me?
I'm talking about tricks used
to go fucking crazy for this hoe.
No cap, I'm talking like...
Man this one trick, we
used to call him Frank,
you heard me?
Bitch don't do nothing
but eat hotdogs all day.
freak the fuck out, you heard me?
One of them old fetish ass dude.
One of them motherfuckers that
want the hoe to lick his ass
and fuck him in the ass and
just freak the fuck out.
But he got that old taste type shit.
You know what I'm saying?
He done want a chocolate ass bitch.
Or he want one of these old
church looking ass white girls
you know what I'm saying.
Excuse me, I put a middle
ring on my pinky finger
'cause I'm married to the game .
You know what I'm saying.
Solid gold ring.
I put that trick on timeout,
fucked up about Bailey.
He wasn't the only one
fucked up about Bailey
you know what I'm saying?
But they get pussy, they get that scene
and they no that they
don't want nothing ever.
I'm talking about, mind go crazy.
If the hoe bug them or don't
want to suck their dick
or don't want to perform
whatever fucked up act,
perverted act they won't
perform they lose it.
I just told you about
the trick that tried.
I had to put the bitch out, on time out.
Booked the bitch without paying the bitch.
You know, my hoe a gangster
so she upped that pocket knife on him.
But that shit just...
that hoe got a gash in her leg
bigger than my goddam fist
you know what I'm saying?
My mamma doctor in on this hoe right now.
- [Interviewer] How
big a part of this life
is stealing the tricks
jewelry, his wallet, his whatever?
- See that's low.
- [Interviewer] Instead
of just sex for money.
- See that's low balling.
When you're dealing with
these old street walking-ass
they had fled back and beat bitches.
You know it, ain't no telling
what you're going to get.
You know what I'm saying?
How might not be a hoe,
she might be a bro.
You need to check shit
you know what I'm saying?
But you know I try to stay in casinos,
And then we trapping off
every little social site.
My Instagram, Facebook messenger,
Snapchat, Baidu,
all the well sites they
ain't looking for nothing.
May best show win, best
show win you heard me?
And that's all they want
you know what I'm saying?
It's all about the pimp.
How you present the hoe and it's enough.
See you've gotta have
a Holy game tight too.
Pimping gotta school these bitches .
You know what I'm saying?
When you dealing with a hoe
don't just know too much ,
you gotta walk hand to hand
with this bitch in a sense
until the how get up and running.
Or you could put a Vid bitch with the BC.
Don't never put two of the same hoes.
You see what I'm saying?
If you knock this hoe and
she fresh in your stable
don't put up with no nother green ass hoe
you just knocked that's
fresh on your stable.
They got too much in common you heard me?
Hoes will break bread with
this bread you heard me?
A hoe ain't never going to leave broke.
You see what I'm saying?
So these two hoes they
got too much in common.
Fresh, you know what I'm saying?
New to the stable, ain't just
got the ins and outs down
they got more break in them
than they got breaking on
you heard me?
When they got break in them
they gonna run, you heard me?
They got break in on they gonna pay,
you see what I'm saying?
Y'all want a hoe that gonna pay and stay
You know what I'm saying?
All that extra shit, look
hoe you can have that.
Have them one of them broke ass niggas,
rock selling around the
corner that want you.
You know what I'm saying.
How I come I let a hoe know out the top,
hoe I don't need you I'm going
to live well off her fees.
Straight like that you
know what I'm saying?
The day you lit a hoe the
day you can get gone man.
You know what I'm saying?
When your money gone get gone with
you know what I'm saying?
Straight like that.
- [Interviewer] How much are
your girls making a night?
- You know.
My bottom bitch, she ain't
just too much for self for sake
cause she handle all my
other little endeavors.
You know what I'm saying?
So, she work primarily,
you know what I'm saying?
That hoe bring in like
$1500 in two weeks though.
So she paying her weight,
you know what I'm saying?
But she just ain't earning
like my other hoes earning.
I'm talking about, hoe
got to walk them out
earning power fucking with
me, you know what I'm saying?
So, with my other three
hoe, I try to temp them man
like five, 600 a night.
You know what I'm saying?
On a good night, like two,
3000, you know what I'm saying?
When we got some good tricks.
You know what I'm saying?
I got some boy be calling
from Mississippi in Jackson, Tennessee.
And shit be spinning like a motherfucker.
Country board, they just
want to smoke their crack,
get their dick sucked
you know what I'm saying?
Then, you know, we got the these
little hired bad tricks in the casino.
You know what I'm saying?
You doll your bitch up
you know what I'm saying?
Put a little money on the
bitch you know what I'm saying?
Have her looking like
something presentable
you know what I'm saying?
I don't want no old snag
two faced hangnail ass bitch
walking up beside me.
Nah, I just jumped out of 2016
you ain't seen the white jump out there.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, hoe, you got to look like me hoe.
You represent me, a reflection of me.
You going to be up to par
you know what I'm saying?
And with that it kind
of dictate the tricks
that you attract you know what I'm saying?
So, you can't catch a shark
with a worm you feel me?
So you got to put the appropriate
bait out for who you want.
So if I'm around like a
corporate sitting or something
you know, I'm going to have
my hoe all the way up to par
designer without the label,
you know what I'm saying?
Real sophisticated ass shit,
I could clean up, nice
talk, walk the walk myself.
I just, you know, I'm, I'm a gang banger.
I'm a street nigga.
Tattoos all over me you
know what I'm saying?
Murder charges on my jack.
You know what I'm saying?
So a hoe can get through
doors that I can't.
you know what I'm saying?
So I led the hoe drive the
concert situation and shit
but the hoe always directed by a pimp.
You know what I'm saying?
For Halle Berry it's a
Tyler Perry remember that
you know what I'm saying?
These hoes be knowing they
good stars, good lookers
and shit but look hoe, you're
lost without direction.
You see what I'm saying?
Even the best hoe need a good pimp.
You know what I'm saying?
So the price is probably vary.
These hoes out in Memphis they
fuck the game up every way
sucking Dick for twenties
and forties and shit.
Nah, that I got out in July,
I got out the penitentiary.
Cause I was trapping in the penitentiary.
You know what I'm saying?
I wasn't on no broke shit
in the penitentiary you.
Pimping and hoeing go on and on.
You know what I'm saying?
Real talk.
Real talk
You know what I'm saying?
I ain't know on no homo shit
I let them boys be the boys.
You know what I'm saying?
This is the big boy
league what I'm saying.
So you know what I'm saying?
We knocking guards, sergeants,
you know what I'm saying.
We fucking the corporate.
We fucking the corporate in
the broom closet type shit
You know what I'm saying?
Making the hoe run the sack.
Getting our bread, out the sack.
You know what?
They pay $50 worth of weed out here.
They pay $200 for in jail you heard me?
You know what I'm saying?
So boom, this hoe like me, whatever.
Like how I talk, how I look,
my dress, all that old shit.
You know what I'm saying?
Everything that attract a
hoe you know what I'm saying?
See if a hoe like you got
one foot in the game already.
You know what I'm saying?
It's on you behind it.
- [Interviewer] That's an important part
of the relationship, right?
The girl has to like you?
- She got to respect you.
See what I'm saying?
Like just a luxury you heard me?
I'm sure my hoes don't like me.
You know what I'm saying?
But they done seen enough you feel me?
They know not to play
you see what I'm saying?
They know not to play.
You know what I'm saying?
Your bottom bitch gotta love you though.
You know.
In my opinion, all your
hoes gotta love you.
Your hoe got to love you though.
Mine fuck fast out here in these streets.
You know what I'm saying it
got to be a level of love.
You see what I'm saying?
Or deep in fashion weight,
whatever you want to call it
whatever the fuck you want
to call it, it got to be it.
You know what I'm saying?
The hoe gotta have some type
of inclination towards you man.
Have to like how you talk, what you ride
what you're saying, what you're doing,
who you around, something.
You see what I'm saying?
For her to do what she do for you?
Nope.
It just like mine.
Imagine a
mamma
you feel me?
Just had their baby
and the house catch on fire.
You know what she going to do?
She gonna run her black ass in there
and fight flames for that baby.
You heard me?
That's how powerful love is you hear me?
Hoes call their pimp daddy.
You see what I'm saying?
I'm their parent you hear me?
You feel me in a sense.
You know what I'm saying?
I ain't make it, but you my baby
you know what I'm saying?
So a hoe gotta love you.
And in the same sense
look I ain't taking
nobody word over my hoe.
You know what I'm saying?
You can't no trick tell me about no hoe.
Can't no other hoe tell me
about my hoe unless she my hoe.
My hoe can tell me
something about my other hoe
you heard me?
Cause that's what she's there for
keep this hoe on her toes you heard me?
Pit these hoes against each other.
I don't care I'll pit these
hoes against each other.
You see what I'm saying?
I might tell this red bitch
man I like this chocolate
thick fine bitch man.
Oh look at that bitch over there.
You see her, look.
You see what I'm saying?
In her mind and her soul conscious.
This what I like, I don't
like her you hear me.
Now she trying to earn it.
You feel me?
She going to work a little
bit hard, a little bit smart.
You know what I'm saying?
And then what you want to do?
You wanna pop the leash you feel me?
Pop the whip screaming,
you already got a leash
around the hoe neck.
You wanna pop that whoop.
Make the hoe work you feel me?
You know what I'm saying,
hoe gotta have a motivation.
You know what I'm saying?
That's why I say a hoe got to feel
like she a part of something powerful.
Hoe don't want to work for
no rinky dinky ass nigga.
Come on man a hoe could
be broke by herself.
You know what I'm saying?
I will ride that big bus to
that big building by ourself.
Hoe want to put it forward man.
You know what I'm saying?
Glowing you know what I'm saying?
You can't present it that way.
Look you in the way.
You know what I'm saying?
And then ain't never been me.
I shoot for the top.
You know what I'm saying?
My older hoe, my second hoe was in jail.
When they got the gash in her lit, fine.
Fine,
you wouldn't even not think
this hoe sucking and fucking
the way she is for this cash.
You heard me?
You be the talk.
You gotta a hoe mind nigga blend
in different circles right?
Cause you don't want to do local Joe shit.
Local Joe gonna keep him broke.
I'm on some big money shit,
I want mines in clumps.
You feel me?
So I got to up the anti.
You know what I'm saying?
You got to do it a little bit different.
Think outside of the box.
Make my own niche.
You see what I'm saying?
So my hoe got other talents too.
You feel me?
Like boosting it, doing her.
You know what I'm saying?
Fraud.
Making fake credentials,
ID's you know what I'm saying?
GED.
I got a hoe right now
man that'll make a ID
for any motherfucking
state I want to go in.
You heard me?
Yeah you got to have hoes
that's multi-talented.
You know what I'm saying?
Come on, get with it.
You can only fuck and suck for so long.
Pussy wear out.
You know what I'm saying?
If you want to, you know what I'm saying?
Keep the hoe in you know what I'm saying?
Have a little bit more longevity
it's all about how you market the hoes.
You feel me?
I ain't going to send no street walker
up in that corporate scene you heard me?
Hoe gonna be out and in there.
I ain't going to know how
to come to the tricks.
I ain't going to know
how to track the tricks
or nothing you hear me?
And then there it is, I'm
going to be frustrated.
I'm gonna beat the bitch.
Or I'm gonna do something up you feel me?
I'm gonna have to go do something
that I wouldn't have to do.
if I would've properly put this together.
You see what I'm saying?
Pimping in mine...
Hey listen.
For something that's so
simple, it's so complicated.
You feel me?
We just make it look easy,
you see what I'm saying?
Cause it's our life you feel me?
If you don't know the rules to the game
then why you playing?
You see what I'm saying?
So me I tried to get around
other pimps.
Then I seen then there's a
thing about pimping too man
They don't just let
motherfuckers into their circle.
You see what I'm saying?
See, I'm blessed in the sense
that I come from
a rural family.
You see what I'm saying?
Like I told you, like my momma
big shit popping in the hood.
Like everybody knows,
you know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
My big brother a real gangster
in the feds right now.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah he beat two bodies.
Like a real gangster.
Like he's the reason
I'm a gangster right now
you know what I'm saying?
I'm proud to say that,
But
with it
I already had...
You know what I'm saying?
Certain little...
We call them pimp bones.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh this little thing got a pimp
bone in his body, he a simp.
You feel me?
I come from a thorough bred family.
So it was already, you
know what I'm saying?
Upbringing.
When pops got killed.
Once I came back to my mom,
man it was streets 101
you know what I'm saying?
Pimps, hookers and
robbing, finessing, fraud.
Whatever you could think of,
Sharon in that hood had
her hand in the pot man.
Had her hand in that jar
you know what I'm saying?
And you know me, I was
proud to say that's my mama
you know what I'm saying?
I would proud to say
this is what we doing.
You know what I'm saying?
You know?
And I went about the
hoes that I dealt with
you know what I'm saying?
From what I was taught,
you see what I'm saying?
So I saved man a hoe
got to compliment you.
You see what I'm saying?
It ain't no what's the
fucking use of having a hoe
that's going to be a conflict of interest.
Every time you turn around
and the hoe got something
to say, that hoe got some bad talk,
this hoe ain't come, this
hoe ain't meeting any quota.
Come on man I'm straight hoe,
why would I need you around me
I can do bad by myself hoe kick rocks.
You heard me?
And me I'm blunt, rude in a sense.
I tell the hoe.
See that's another thing too,
you gotta be unapologetic.
In this dope, in this
pimp game you feel me?
What I say is what I mean.
Hoe you can suck my Dick from the back.
If you think any other thing you feel me?
All about the pimping baby.
All I'm saying.
My life real.
My struggle real know what I'm saying?
Anything a motherfucker want to know
they could Google this shit,
this shit black and white.
You know what I'm saying?
All of us up on the island
know this shit is truth.
You feel me?
You know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] Super interesting.
- [Pimping] For sure.
- [Interviewer] Good luck with everything,
stay out of prison.
- [Pimping] For sure man.
- [Interviewer] Take care of your girls.
- [Pimping] I appreciate that homie.
- [Interviewer] Thanks man.
- [Pimping] It was a wrap, bitch
the hype is over, that way.